[Music]
hello film independent members and
welcome to this film independent
presents q a for the oscar shortlisted
documentary short camp confidential
america's secret nazis
[Music]
the first memory i have is when we were
told we were going to be taken to 1142
this is not a very military camp
here you have no rank no titles you
can't tell anybody what you're cool this
was a secret operation it took a few
weeks to be told nazis were going to be
there
as a jewish refugee from europe that's
just about as bizarre an assignment as
you could get
rocket scientists who were
essential to the nazi war effort
now
becoming
essential to our war effort
i'm john wilson senior programmer with
film independent i want to special thank
you to the hfpa and our sponsor vision
media who hosts our film independent
presents virtual screening room and now
please welcome today's guests writer
director and producers of camp
confidential
daniel savon and more luci
thank you for having us thank you for
joining me today
um
that's extremely exciting news being
shortlisted uh for
for the oscar short
um congratulations to you not many
people make it there
and
did you did you have to play the short
in a qualifying festival for it to
qualify to
to submit to the oscars this year
i'm not sure i mean we were screening at
doc nyc and the afi
but
we got here somehow no i mean yeah we
were at doc nyc
shortlisted which was you know terrific
and
we were so fortunate to have this small
window between you know everyone
starting to get back and meet each other
at doc nyc and afi
and now everything is back to virtual
so actually you know we had screenings
with audience which you know in the last
two years
is something that we really have to to
think about that we had that opportunity
of actually screening it to in in a
really amazing two film festivals right
i used to um
watch short films for the la film
festival and we would get uh just our
festival three thousand submissions so
there's many thousands of short films
made in a year
and uh you know it's a tough competition
for this
um so let's start with um
you know we're a
an organization with a lot of filmmaker
members
so i like to start
q and a's a lot of times with the
question of
um what's your filmmaker origin story so
for each of you how did you become a
filmmaker more do you want to start
sure
so actually my journey started i mean
sometimes
i can't even believe that you know
since i was 15
you know i had uh i learned films in
high school
and somehow you know i was hooked
immediately and i knew that that's what
i wanted to do and uh and then i
finished high school and
you know i started working almost
immediately
and and uh and then i went to film
school here in israel in
jerusalem
film school which is a great film school
and
between i think my first year to my
second year
you know i needed money to support
my study
and and i wanted to make money for the
summer
and do you remember back in the days
when there was a you know digitizing
like tapes that you had
into the computer
and the digitizers would work from 8 p.m
until 8 a.m you know because the editors
used to work on the day time
and so then i met daniel
and
and
we work together every day since 8 00 pm
to 8 am in the morning
and we fell in love and i started
working on a documentary film
and he when i met him so he already won
like first prize you know on on like in
this israeli film festival so
i started working on a documentary and
he told me why are you doing it through
film school you know just like quit film
school
let's use the tuition money um to
produce the film i'll produce the film
for you i'll edit the film for you and
so
i left film school
i moved in with daniel and um
and we started making films together
and uh yeah and our career began mostly
with political films here you know the
situation in israel is
is pretty
you know difficult and
for many many years we we made political
dog films and you know we were very
fortunate
that uh censored voices and also diaries
that we did together
uh got into sundance and you know to the
berlinale and so yeah so our career
you know almost i think since the first
film we made
somehow you know reached
uh
these amazing you know places and stages
so
and yeah and it's been um
25 years since so uh
i can't believe that i'm 40. i i didn't
realize that story was also going to be
a love story that was amazing wow
terrible
uh
daniel do you have a different viewpoint
on that story or would you say that
do you have a different viewpoint to
that story i want to hear
no i'm i'm
i i started at my peak and i'm just
deteriorating every year because i
started as an activist
and i would do these political
docs you know just like
uh
you know do-it-yourself docs and it was
all activism and running around and
getting shot at
and from here to here it became more and
more bourgeoisie and it became like
okay like you know this demonstration
like we shot a million demonstrations
how about like we do
something more interesting and maybe a
bit more cinematic and for me to hear
you know leaving the activism and
becoming
more and more of a bourgeoisie
filmmaker now
we've reached our peak with like making
animation which is
the most
safe and comfortable way of not running
in the trenches with a camera so i i
always feel a bit ashamed that like
i i left the activism for others and now
we are we are making films now we're
still in the trenches
we're still in the trenches and i think
you know that every project has its
challenges and you know it's creative
thinking
every film brings you know
some kind of worries
and
when you do animation you don't get tear
gas like you know
on a daily basis you you get annoyed
it's true but you know i think
camp confidential was
it was no it was extremely important and
i think that you know in all of our
filmmaking and you know i disagree on
what because you know
this story i think is very connected to
to our previous career
i think that we always are looking for
subjects
which are you know censored
and subjects and voices of people that
were silenced for many many years
and i think you know that this line of
of what we're looking for you know these
dark
secrets in in in history
of us as human society uh um
are really you know this is our passion
and i think that also kept confidential
it's pretty political film if you know
if i may say
because you know it has those elements
that
are you know
keep you know like drove us
to this project yeah so can we talk
about um the origins of of camp
confidential what is it that led you to
want to tell this particular story
so we were wrapping up the devil next
door which is a netflix series
about john de mienyok which was this
nazi guard
from cleveland and it was a very tough
documentary to make because it was
really spending two years with
holocaust imagery and really terrible
stories and we were approached by benji
and jono bergman um right at the end the
producers told us about this story and
our immediate reaction was a
we can't cope with another story of that
magnitude about the holocaust it's just
such an emotional toll and b we just
don't believe you like you know it
sounded just like an urban legend about
this
camp in the middle of the war with jews
guarding nazis it sounded like some kind
of sick joke
and
once we started actually listening to
the nps recordings and then when we met
arno and peter we just were shocked that
like everything they pitched us was
actually reality and still like you know
watching it again and again i i still
just can't believe that this happened
because it's it really sounds like a
twisted joke
yeah i mean when they especially i i
remember you know when they approached
us
they told us about the story of a
vernafone brown
taken by the you know jewish refugees uh
to the landsberg brothers store buying
lingerie for their wives to send to
germany and i couldn't believe it
because sometimes
people imagine things when they want you
know to pitch your projects and i i i
said to myself i don't believe that the
story is actually true
and when we heard it in all of the
testimonies you know the story over and
over and then when we interviewed arno
and peter
when we heard the story and we
understood that it's true and we
understood the origin of it you know
it's it was shocking and
it even you know it it hurted it's you
know it's it
it's ironic it's funny but at the same
time
it makes you feel so angry and it makes
you feel you know okay something here
went completely wrong
how could this even happen and this
relationship
between the jewish refugees
and the nazis i think you know
really really interested us
what did they felt you know what was
this journey for them
what was exactly the story we really
were
we wanted to hear more and more so
do you know if
it was really interesting to me you know
of course they wanted people that could
speak german to you know interrogate the
nazis but why in particular did they
want jewish people
to be the jailers in this situation were
all the jailers
jewish
so the vast majority were jewish um the
real vast majority i think there were
like three people who weren't jewish in
the whole camp
and
the answer is very simple it's
it was a war everybody was suspected
everybody who knew german was suspected
of being a nazi and
the jews were the people that were
obviously not nazis so they were just
picked up from the boot camp and it was
just oh you know german
are you jewish great like we have a
mission for you
i don't think they thought about it too
much they were just looking for people
that knew fluent german
that could have you know done this job
and there was a community of of
jewish refugees that arrived from
germany right when they were
16 17 most of them escaped
you know like
without their parents even
that they were running away from this
horrors in germany and and they came
there when they were
teenagers and were drifted to the army
two years later one year later so they
were actually even still germans they
they most of them didn't even have
american citizenship yet they were enemy
aliens they were considered enemy aliens
and so i think that the army sees it of
this opportunity
of saying oh okay these are real germans
they can you know they can do this job
and i don't think that they thought
about it too much about the situation
where okay these jewish refugees
their families are murdered right at
this moment in germany and they're
supposed to treat those nazis nicely i
don't think that they really thought it
through because if they did
this is
heartbreaking
yeah i it's it's pretty it's a pretty
shocking
uh as you said you didn't believe that
it existed and and i just felt the same
thing watching it like i can't believe
this really happened
um and how shocking it must have been to
these people who had fled
europe to get away from the nazis and
now they would be spending you know all
their time
with them um how long of a period of
time was it that they uh were
doing this with um camp cop
the camp
the camp existed for four years
and it was different periods of time for
each
and some stayed a few months some stayed
a whole year some stayed a few weeks
and they really formed relationship with
them i mean some of them even befriended
them on some levels um many of them the
vast majority were really sickened by
them
and tormented by them and it's amazing
like you know we we keep talking to
peter even today he's 96 now
and he's still in every conversation
says it again and again he says like
if i would have been tasked with this
today i would have said no i would have
never done it today and peter went on
and became a very very influential and
prominent civil rights lawyer and really
changed some
anti-torture laws into europe in the u.n
and he says if if i wasn't a refugee if
i wasn't 18 i would say no and he still
feels the need to apologize and say like
you know i am sorry for what i've done
and
we're like very
empathic of course and and keep telling
him like look like you know
those were your orders you you you had
to follow them back then but
it's uh it's still haunting them
yeah and the the camp exists from 42
1942 to 1946
and i think that that is like
it's not only after the war
it's during the awards four years during
the war and then the camp was bulldozed
all the documents were burned
um
everything was bulldozed in 1946 i think
that the us knew how problematic this
camp was how problematic
uh you know things that happened there
was and and i think that
they wanted to whitewash those crimes in
order to
to allow vonafon brown and the
scientists to join nasa and to join you
know
forces with the us uh
for one mission for you know to get to
the moon before the soviet union
and that's you know makes you think
uh about you know interest
that countries are
taking decisions
uh and you know what are exactly the red
lines as us as human society as to those
decisions
yeah this is i would say this
documentary because i i had heard before
i think everybody's heard before you
know that there are nazis here in the
united states and
um everybody sort of
wondered how they got here and
um
sort of you know the idea that the
united states might have harbored them
and i think this is really the first
time you know i'm seeing
an actual explanation for that and an
actual acknowledgement of
we did bring them here we did harbor
them we did bring their families we did
give them citizenship and
and
good jobs so yeah it's completely
understandable why the united states
but you know they succeeded in it taking
a long time to uncover that um
and it's not only high jobs i mean what
was you know it's it's
one of the people you know that
actually was
on apollo 11 the kennedys embraced
vernafon brown
president after president you know
embraced him you see in the archives at
the end of the film how the u.s audience
you know clapping him and
and and
looking at him as a hero as an american
hero that reached apollo 11. by the way
like one of the most obnoxious
characters that you know made his way
through the camp
was one of hitler's chief chemists
and after the war he was recruited and
served on the board of all these
pharmaceutical companies in the u.s
and he ended up inventing thalidomides
that terrible terrible
medicines that caused so much harm and
others were recruited by the cia of
course and by other corporations and it
was really
a very solid interest in saying like we
have the national interest of the us
becoming stronger
and the enemy of our enemy is our friend
but what is what was for us at least
like so disturbing
is back when they were actually
interrogating them and you can see that
in the fourth part first part of the
film
is they did not interrogate them about
what was a hitler's weapon
what kind of rifles did they use they
interrogated them most of all about hey
like you fought on the eastern front
what do the russians have what kind of
tanks does stalin have
and it was really preparing the war
against russia
very much during the
the second world war and they
very very
you know knowingly
um prepared themselves into the next war
and it wasn't just
you know winning against hitler yes that
was quite a revelation as well that um
we were already
in a competition with russia
to steal the most scientists from
germany
um
just it's crazy um so talk about the
animation in this at what point did you
decide
that telling the story with animation
was
the best way to do it
um
it was a very easy process that followed
shouts and arguments and
things hurled at each other in the house
i was like wow it's gonna be amazing
it's animation
and more was like i hate cartoons i hate
animation i i hate anything that is not
like dead realistic because she's really
such an archive buff and we really rely
on archives in all of our films
and here we had no archives and like one
option
was
okay we're just gonna listen but when we
listen to these testimonies it's lacking
something because they really they
portray something so human but it's it
doesn't you know come through through
the audio and we really didn't want to
work with actors and recreations because
we are talking about the holocaust and
we didn't want any kind of holocaust
deniers popping out and saying oh you
know they recreated it so so who knows
um so for us it was very clear that we
needed some kind of solution
and
yes take it from here i mean at the end
of the day of course that he convinced
me but and but i think you know that
because we're a couple that is working
together so the dialogue is
is i think
at the end of the day the film really
benefits from it because it was pretty
even after we decided to go on animation
so
it was very important for me you know
not to go in a childish animation to go
on a certain type of animation that
would be like an adult animation that
i wanted to see face i want i mean the
animation was a tool that we can you
know express the feelings of the people
because us as even
when we approached animation we're still
documentary people you know and
we wanted the emotion there that was
what was so important for us and that's
what we insisted all throughout the
process even you know to go and i think
it was a part of the this dialogue when
exactly which style of animation to go
that you know will be able to really
touch in a very deep way
on how the characters felt and to give
the viewer this journey that even if
you're like me not a cartoon fan you
know you would still be very very
connected to it and i think
that it was the best decision for the
film
it was and also as an archive buff also
you know
when we move into the animation
after you see venaphone brown in the
animation then you actually see the real
archives and vernafone brown sitting
there in the room
looking you know through the control
room of apollo 11
it feels like
like yeah like a punch in the stomach
that's exactly
what we wanted you know
to gain and and that's exactly the
question that we wanted to raise uh
throughout the film so i think i think
this mix
was a really really successful mix for
this film
yes i do too i feel like
in the last couple of years there's been
a lot more a lot more documentary
filmmakers using um the form of
animation in their film and it's really
interesting how you can
can tell a story in that way
when you need to create something for an
audience that doesn't necessarily
already exist on film or
that you would would have to shoot
um
so let's um
the so the film's currently on
streaming on netflix right
yes that's right um
at what point
did you um make a deal with netflix to
stream the movie
so it was like right from the
very start i mean
we had this idea and we immediately
emailed them and told them like we have
a wonderful short for you
and thank god or thank
netflix for
i mean hopping on board because it's
really it's impossible to
to work with animation on a you know
independent budget and it was amazing
having their support and also it was
very clear for us from day one that we
wanted to make it as a short format we
wanted it to be a real punch in the
stomach and not to be dragged out into a
episodic or into a long format but just
this is a camp these are the voices this
is what happened and no experts nothing
but that and in the past like working
with different broadcasters um
there was no slot for this i mean people
would tell us like you know unless it's
gonna be a 90 it won't get into
festivals and we won't get like a
theatrical release and it's just so
beautiful that netflix you know brought
back to life this format of these
40-minute films which is fantastic
because like we were watching all of the
shorts in the in the short list and we
absolutely loved them it was such a
great experience i think that you know
first
john and benji approached us and then
immediately
when we heard about the idea we said
okay there are 94.
so the first step was hopping on a plane
we're living in l.a hopping on a plane
to dc we filmed them
and then we approached netflix i mean we
didn't want to waste time you know yeah
we immediately did the interviews
and
and then and then we immediately wrote
netflix and email and uh
you know please be on board and it's so
wonderful that that
they were our partners because
they were really really great and
terrific to work with and supporting
this project
it was it was a fantastic
journey especially you know with covered
ears
uh two years to do animation was
was very
yeah good experience
i've been watching the oscars since i
was a kid and
the shorts
you know the schwartz categories were
notoriously
uh
how do i say not cared about that much
but i think it's it was because people
really didn't have a way to view them so
it is fantastic you know that they're
being streamed now for a lot of people
um to actually get to see all the shorts
um
in the in the shorts categories um
because that format is is completely i
think the shorts format it's completely
amazing
it has not only helped filmmakers get
their start in filmmaking but some
filmmakers continued to make films in
that format do you think you will
still continue to make films in a
shorter format
i think it depends on the project you
know i think it depends
on what we want to do or the hook
actually
you know
we had a very long career before we did
this short of feature films and series
i mean
so
this is the first time we actually made
shorts you know after 20 years
in the industry so
and it was such a wonderful experience i
mean
so you know i think it depends
on on the story on the project and
like daniel said you know the fact that
now you have
netflix you know brought back those
shorts
so you can choose you can really really
choose what's best for each project what
is the best outcome to reach the best
film is it 40 minutes is it 90 or is it
four episodes i think that
each project comes with its own life
decision and
yeah i think that docs are
you know yeah i mean i would have made a
different film than another filmmaker
would have done
but the material talks and usually the
material and the footage and the story
takes you to the place
that you know that they choose you and
and not otherwise
well thank you so much
um for joining me to talk about this
um don't feel bad for loving archival i
do too so
we're we'll be uh we'll be archival
nerds together
yeah
put me in an archive and just
um
yeah thank you so much um
congratulations and um you know good
luck to you at the oscars
thank you thank you so much
thanks for having us
[Music]
you